because the sixteen-year-old can actively vote,
this is now in the far
Part of Germany the case.
In Vienna,
however,
weak counter-arguments are cited.
for example,
that young people
allegedly still too un at this age
or also very popular
and manges better arguments often repeated.
when we lower the voting age,
then we must also support the youth
punish as severely as the adults.
very fond of cleaning up.
and finally I would like to go to 1 counterargument
refer that I have often heard
and that probably
probably really the list of the worst
Arguments.
the left
or,
as the case may be,
all other parties to the left of the
political spectrum
want with the lowering of the voting age yes only the
increase own error base.
well,
young people vote very differently.
just as there is no youth,
there is also no one party,
that young people choose.
i can reassure them,
they don't just vote left,
yes,
they also vote conservative
and unfortunately they also choose right and right extreme.
That's the way it is.
but that's just it,
what we from the advocates this really bad
argument differs quite fundamentally.
unlike those who put forward this argument,
we are not about the
supposedly expected election result,
but for the granting of a fundamental right.
and independently of it,
what people end up with their fundamental right,
also take up the right to vote in the end.
dear deputies decoalition,
they give themselves a jolt and don't let them,
that Saxony will once again be at the forefront.
and very honored departure under the CDU
they approve our bill.
let them vote for the 16 and seventeen year olds.
perhaps some of them would then
even vote for the CDU.
thank you very much.